post Malone and Joe Rogan talked for
four hours while recording their second
ever podcast episode together comedy and
music fans were stoked to see this
crossover happen again but listeners
were even more excited to see Tim Dylan
back in the hot seat just days later for
his 12th round on The Joe Rogan
Experience it's hard to find a better
podcast combination than Joe and Tim
whether they're talking on JRE or the
Tim Dylan show these two have a unique
and established back and forth that gets
put on full display behind the mics
which is exactly why their episode ended
up trending number one in the world
beating out postie by just one spot the
rock star was in Austin to promote his
new album named Austin and while he was
there